[موسيقى]
ما فعلناه هو دمج سيارة
فورمولا 1 مع طائرة السباق بدون طيار وتحويلها إلى
شيء جديد تمامًا ، من الأسهل
بناء سيارة طائرة تحوم ، ما
أردنا القيام به هو التسابق عندما تريد
الزيادة لتحتاج إلى قدر هائل من
القوة سريعة جدًا جدًا ، هذه طائرة
كهربائية متعددة المروحيات مأهولة
بنسبة طاقة إلى وزن أكبر من سيارة f1
أو سرعات نفاثة مقاتلة تصل إلى 200
كيلومتر في الساعة عبر الهواء 2020 ،
إنها قادمة بسرعة
وستكون أول سيارة طيران  الجائزة الكبرى
هي خمس فرق وعشرة طيارين وعشرة مركبات
في حلبة السباق وجهاً لوجه ،
لذا فليس هذا وقتًا للتجربة ،
إنه سباق وجهاً لوجه من
شبكة انطلاق ، فالهواء هو في الواقع
وسيط بسيط للغاية  للعمل معها
في العديد من الطرق ، يمكننا بناء رياضة أكثر أمانًا
مما كان ممكنًا في تلك
اللوحات على مدار القرن الماضي ، هناك
أشياء يمكنك القيام بها في الهواء لم
تكن ممكنة لم تكن ممكنة في
رياضة السيارات ،  أشياء مذهلة مع
الروبوتات والاستقلالية ثا  نذهب إلى
أنظمة التحكم في الطيران لدينا والتي تجعل الأمور
آمنة ، لذا حماية الطيارين من فعل
أي شيء إلى الاصطدام الرهيب ببعضهم
البعض
، أعتقد أن هذه الأنواع من الأشياء ستكون
الرياضة الأكثر مشاهدة في العالم